when John fetterman decided to debate  Mehmet Oz there were many perspectives  as to whether that was a smart decision  or not and it turns out that it kind of  made no difference when we actually now  got polling we saw that fetterman's  favorability rating  was at 48 percent before the debate as  well as after the debate this is from a  Civics that's where the Civics with a Q  poll and so for all of the discussions  about it was tough to watch it was tough  to watch fetterman struggle and did Oz  capitalize or didn't hear what's going  to happen next at the end of the day  it seems like it didn't make a  difference and fetterman ended up with  not a huge but a very solid win in  Pennsylvania to go on to be the next  Senator thankfully not Mehmet Oz